في غضون ذلك نقلت شبكه ار ان دي الالمانيه
متحدث باسم شركه اورانج ميتال الدفاعيه
الالمانيه ان الشركه قد تسلم
139 دبابه لبارج القتاليه الى اوكرانيا
اذا لازما الامر وذلك في حال موافقه
الحكومه الالمانيه اضافر متحدث ان راين
ميتال يمكنها تسليم 29 دبابه لبارد اثنين
بحلول ابريل الى مايو اثنتين و20 دبابه
اخرى من الطراز نفسه في نهايه العام
الجاري او اوائل العام المقبل وقال
المتحدث ان بامكان الشركه ايضا تسليما نحو
تسعين دبابه لبارد واحد الاقدم دون تحديد
اطار زمنيه محتمل
معنى من خلصان مراسل الجزيره تامر صمادي
تامر مرحبا بك معنا ونحن في متابعه هذه
الاخبار المتعلقه بلبارد واحد مثلا هل من
الممكن ان تصل هل هنالك متابعه اوكرانيه
لوصول دبابات قبيله ابريل وهو الموعد يعني
المتوقع اثنين
بالفعل هذا ما يؤمل هنا المؤمل لهنا في
اوكرانيا محمد يعني كل التصريحات الصادره
عن كبار الاوكرانيين بالاضافه الى القاده
العسكريين تشير ايه الى ذلك وهنالك في
الحقيقه صاحب تعبير ضغط مكثف تواصله
الدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
بشكل مباشر بالاضافه قبل ذلك الرئيس
الاوكراني الذي لا يترك همم فرصه الا
ويذكر بضروره ارسال تلك الدبابات ويقول
بانها سوف تؤثر بشكل كبير على مجريات
المعركه خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله وفي الحقيقه ايضا
كان هناك تصريح لافتت اندريا يرمك خلال
ساعات الماضيه وهو المستشار في الرئاسه
همم الاوكرانيه الذي قال ايضا ميخائيل
البدلات الذي قال نحن لا نحتاج الى ااا
عشرات الدبابات وانما لمئات الدبابات
ويتحدث عن ان تلك الدبابات سوف تغير
بالفعل في شكل المعركه وسوف تغير الكفه في
الارض لصالح القوات الاوكرانيه وفي
الحقيقه كانت هنالك تصريحات مهمه على وقع
تلك المطالبات وتلك الضغوط ولذلك الحراك
الدبلوماسي الذي تبذله اوكرانيا للتسريع
في ارسال تلك الدبابات ومزيد من الاسلحه
والعتاد الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه التي قالت
ايضا يوم امس بان الربيع المقبل بالاضافه
الى نهايه الصيف اوائل الصيف سوف تكون
هنالك تغييرات جذريه في المعركه وربما
تنتهي الحرب كما تؤمن اوكرانيا لصالحها
وتحدثت ايضا الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه عن
تكثيف القصف الروسي على جنوب اوكرانيا حيث
نقف هنا في خيرسون القصف لا يهدا لا يتوقف
بل القوات الروسيه
السلطات الاوكرانيه وتحديدا الاداره
العسكريه في خيرسون تتحدث عن عشرات
العمليات الهجوميه خلال الساعات الماضيه
فقط الليله الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم للقوات
الروسيه قصف مكثف بالمدفعيه برجمه
الصواريخ بقذائف الهاون على قلب المدينه
وعلى العديد من القرى والبلدات الواقعه
على طول خطا التماس بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه الاسيه عندها ضفتين هاردينيبر
القوات الاوكرانيه تقول بانها تكفف من قصف
المواقع الروسيه عند الضفه الشرقيه من نهر
دنيبر وتتحدث في نفس الوقت عن مزيد من
التعزيزات سواء المتعلقه بمزيد من الافراد
او بالعتاد هذه التعزيزات التي تصل تباعا
من شبه جزيره القرم وفقا للقوات
الاوكرانيه ولذلك تقول هيئه الاركان وتقول
الجيش الاوكراني طيله اليومين الماضيين
وقياده عمليات الجن الاوكرانيه تحديدا بان
قواتها تكثف من قصفها لخطوط الاسناد التي
او الامداد كما وصفتها من شبه جزيره القرم
باتجاه خيرسون ايضا التطورات متلاحقه في
ميكولايف المجاوره تتحدث السلطات المحليه
الاوكرانيه عن قصف مكثف للبنيه التحتيه لا
سيما في المناطق الساحليه والحديد دون
تحديدا عن منطقه
همم التطور الابرص هو في خلال الساعات
الماضيه كانت هنالك تصريحات مهمه لالقياد
العسكريه الاوكرانيه في زبرجيا التي قالت
بان خطوط الدفاع الاماميه بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه لن تخضع لاي تغييرات خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين وهذا النفي واضح وصريح
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه لما يروج روسيا
والروايه الروسيه التي تقول بان قواتها
تقدمت خلال اليومين الماضيين على اكثر من
محور في زبرجه القوات الاوكرانيه هناك
وتحديدا المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه
في زبرجها في خيرسون ايضا يقول بان القوات
الاوكرانيه في المقاطعه الجنوبيه كي تمكنت
بالفعل من دفع القوات الروسيه التي كانت
تحاول التقدم طيله اليومين الماضيين
باتجاه مواقعها السابقه محمد والحديث هنا
بالتاكيد على الريف الجنوبي حيث تمركز
القوات الروسيه لاسيه من التوبيل وتوكماك